[音楽]
danejones
今日は皆さんに自由への切符をお渡ししたくてここに立っています
この言葉が今日のキーワードですレッテル付け
一体皆さんはこのレッテル付けという言葉に対してどんなイメージ
どんな印象をお持ちでしょうか
これから私が簡単な自己紹介をしますので是非私に対してどんなレッテル月をなさるの
か体験してみてください
こんにちはあゆなが真です私は今までいろんな仕事をやってきました
スノーボードでじぇ日本チャンピオンとなってワールドカップ
プロサーキットを転戦したり
国際性の客す乗務員は10年以上やりました
世界のいろんな町や国としに行くことができました
クチコミビジネスでは大きな組織をつくりました私の組織は海を越えて世界へと広がっ
ていきました
ニューヨークに住んで写真の学校に通って
フォトグラファーとなって写真集を出版したりもしたんです
最近までやっていた仕事は言語台は両機を扱う
人工知能の開発販売をする会社のマーケティングの総責任者
cmo でした
さてみなさまはいったい私に対してどんな印象を持ちになったでしょうか
どんなレッテル付けを私に対してなさったでしょうか
今までよく言われたのは頑張り屋さんだねっ
チャレンジャーだね
何でもできるんだねー
すごいねこんなものが多かった気がします
でも実はこれがとても苦しかったんです
今日はそんなお話です
何かを達成しても何の満足感もなくてその満足感のない自分自身が
感謝が足りないと責めるような人生を生きてきました
日本語でしゃべる人工知能の開発を通じてこの
レッテル付けという作業人間特有のものであると気づきました
レッテル付けを人工知能に加えますと人工知能がより人間らしくなるんです
それぞれの人が持つレッテルこそがその人の個性を表し
そして個性その人らしさそんなものをビル生み出す
素晴らしくてとっても大切な要素です
しかし一方でこのレッテルは私たちの人生の物の見方なんかに制限をつけて聴いては
生きづらささえも生み出す要素にもなります
言い換えますとレッテル付けは先入観固定観念
既成概念あるいは思い込みなんかという言葉に言い換えられるかもしれません
さらに私は
人が自分に貼っているレッテルと自分が自分で貼っているれてるとの間にも大きな乖離
があることに気づきました
私子供の頃
大人たちにあんたは本何グッズやな
さっさとしなさいでよく言われたんです
私は子供の頃から自分に
グズでのろまで人に迷惑をかける存在だというレッテルをずっと張ってました
それだけではありません自分が馬鹿だとか
自分はダメだとかそんなレッテルを付箋のようにペタペタと貼っていつしかそれはもう
紙粘土のようにがたく
硬くなってしまっていました
私が自分に貼っている最大のレッテルに気づいたのは
仕事を辞めて結果何の肩書もないただの人になったときです
それは誰かが
誰かの役に立ててないともしくは何かに貢献できている自分でないと
自分には価値がないというレッテルだったんです
日々の忙しさから一転して何の予定もない毎日を過ごす中で
南の方が気もない私にそれまでと変わらずに接してくれる人たちの存在がこのレッテル
を打ち消してくれました
スノーボードれ西日本チャンピオンとなって世界最速公式にですね
日本最速となってもなおグッズというレッテルせ自分ではがせなかった私はこの人たち
のおかげで
私には歌詞がないことないぞとあるんだと気付くことができたんです
レッテルは気づくだけでバリバリと剥がれ始めました
一番硬い大きなレッテルがはがれるとダメとか馬鹿とかグッズとかそんな小さな
レッテルは魚のうろこのようにポロポロと剥がれてきました
はがれてみて初めてわかったことがあります私の人生の一番の足かせは自分が自分に
貼ってしまっている
ベッテルだったんです
レッテルという制限が取れてそこには自由が生まれました
口福堂が上がりました
お参りの人からはキラキラしているねとさえ言われるようになったんです
無職なのにです
今日は皆さんに
私が自分の息子にだけ20年以上言い続けている言葉を送って私が話を終わりにしたい
と思います
あなたは息をしているだけで
100点満点の500店
息をしているだけです
この言葉が昔の私みたいに頑張ってる人たち
自分には価値がないと思っちゃってるような人たちに届けばいいなと思います
そしてみなさんが知らないうちに自分自身に貼ってしまっているレッテルに気付く
きっかけになれたらとてもとても嬉しいです
皆さんが進む自由へのちょっと先でお待ちしていますありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]